[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
to quote Jack Skellington compounded all
I love it though it takes a king of
Halloween to introduce another king of
Halloween
[Music]
he's given us great story after great
story and great hilarity after great
hilarity but bad Stephen King films and
miniseries have been a highlight every
nostalgia tween and this year we're
starting right off with it and boy do we
have a good one for you
I am legit Diddy I can't contain my
giddiness holding my giddiness over
there this might be the funniest Stephen
King movie ever funnier than Maximum
Overdrive funnier than the Tommyknockers
maybe even funnier than it which has Tim
Curry as a cloud that is an
accomplishment
ladies and gentlemen sleepwalkers
[Applause]
released in 1992 lockers got panned by
critics and barely turned into profit
but the impact it left on people who did
see it will last for eons because it
wasn't exactly a monster hit when it
came out it's on the verge of being lost
to obscurity we cannot let this happen
Xuan in theaters show it in rental
stores showing it your children's
birthdays Krista the one you don't like
and then to the one you really don't
like sleepwalkers must live again so
with my giddiness ready to burst can't
you write one year where we're not
covered in blood if I did I know I'd be
doing something wrong
this is leap walkers is it Christmas yet
why it's just gonna cover some more
blood oh the film opens with the
definition god I love it when the
dictionary writes the movie for you
Christ shape-shifting felines vampires
remember when it was just a funny thing
Donald Duck did don't know but Phil's
trying to destroy itself before it even
starts either there they're upping the
terror with a bonanza homage trust me by
the time this movie's over that could be
valid we get a unique crime scene to say
the least
somebody sure doesn't like cats this is
the first shot the Films opening scene
is Luke Skywalker examining Alps
all-you-can-eat buffet as far as I'm
concerned this movie can do no wrong
apart from forgetting to time-travel to
get H John Benjamin to say that's like
now it's in there
I'm totally on board for this ride
[Music]
well in most horror movies this will be
a fake out with a cat but is that a
little too predictable at this point
keep the sci-fi be more letdown if it
did or didn't do that okay I'd be
disappointed either way at least they
had a little extra though damn
catapulting bodies yelling hours after
they're dead they find as the corpse of
a kid carrying a rose in her hair you
know fun fact I let the director know I
didn't think my character what's a rose
it was too cynical and bitter for
someone who was still optimistic I never
mind even the titles a clue for the kind
of movie you're about to see don't you
just want the secret of the ooze written
under it this better have a vanilla ice
wrap it doesn't help either that the
credits give us some pretty hilarious
pictures to follow
yeah cast your vote terrifying or Monty
Python cartoon this one looks like
somebody erased a dick that a kid drew
in earlier everything about this looks
like the opening to Catwoman
that's not a flattering comparison male
like a demure
you know they really should clarify that
is this Shawshank Redemption Stephen
King or Maximum Overdrive Stephen King
I'm excited too we fade in ahaha sorry I
had that reaction whenever King story
isn't set in Maine we fade in on Indiana
the anti Maine if you will where a man
named Charles played by Brian Krause is
busy rubbing a plastic knife on his arm
with blood coming out the top like most
growing boys Tanya I forgot how to spell
the rest of your name so I'll just
output T he goes downstairs to Mary
played by Alice Krige who looks out at
the increasing number of cats around
their house which he sets traps for that
actually looked like a real trap how
many cats did they go through on this
shoot Charles have married danced
through the house while discussing the
romantic future together
going anywhere tonight to the movies
maybe actually there's a girl that works
there jealous
[Music]
ooh things are getting interesting I
didn't know that Stephen King wrote such
steamy scenes early on no yes
the way they caress each other's bodies
the sounds they lips make when they
interlock mother and son yeah but that's
not important the way they look into
each other's eyes is nasty-ass shit yeah
I don't need to see any erotic thriller
from Norman Bates would it make any
difference if I told you there was a 15
year difference between them know if
you're going against what one critic
called sexy and sleek I don't know what
to think of you anymore
the feeling is very mutual what's with
this scene where they're walking into
the bedroom when a purple light shines
out the window well I just assumed
there's so much incest in their family
that their jizz naturally glowed purple
hem levels of uncomfortable I didn't
know existed look if you just read
King's original story you'll see how
much better he's blamed there is no
original story what this started off as
a screenplay there wasn't a book or
anything yeah you don't have to pretend
that there's a better version out there
that you're never gonna read this is
what he wrote oh my god this is a OEE
super you in a totally any now if it
were his sister that'd be different
because that would be really you II I
need a therapist
I don't welcome movie theater one of the
custodians named Tanya is rocking to the
nineties hip
do you love me as Charles walks in on
her I never did figure out why we left
popcorn up there I can't reach it and
people can steal it oh well how about we
get some slush like that muddy snow you
find under the car please enjoy is the
health inspector will be closing us down
soon Thanks scene class welcome to
Travis thanks lad I'll celebrate by
being the only go looking guy alone at a
theater to watch a movie nobody's seeing
suspicions you can use them so the next
day at school yeah school because both
of them are totally teenagers guys let's
do some birthday search and this totally
teenagers guys they go to class with
other 20-somethings taught by Glenn
Shaddix I suggest that next time you
keep your hands to yourself mr. Crawford
I suggest not shooting a scene like I'm
having missionary sex with Bob from
demolition man sir after having the
class in the library because the
classroom would be too obvious Tanya
brings Charles to her house oh no he
must not discover I put on underwear
Christ she's in a breathing heavy at the
idea of him finding out where does she
think she is reefer madness the Lord
knows I think they smoked a joint or two
to say some of this dialogue my favorite
pictures over there that would I like
rice let it be known that one of our
most celebrated writers got paid to
write the line I like rocks I like rice
just then an aging George Lucas watched
this film saying to himself I can
dialogue like that except in stuff like
it be hate and instead of rocks maybe
something smaller like like like Charles
drives home but it's taught by his
teacher who wants to have a talk with
him on the side of the road
all those mid driving student teacher
talks the transcripts are also fakes
clever fakes but
fakes the teacher discovers that Charles
lied about where he came from and is
blackmailing him for sexual favors huh
who do you think you are my mother
I'll be right back after the restroom I
have me too actually
oh you want me to pause it honestly the
movies kind of losing me yeah it's just
creepy adults hitting on teens and I
don't want to see that oh come on maybe
something more traditionally crazy
Stephen King will happen matter of fact
the teacher is about all this not only
does he nonchalantly say he's sorry
while running away from a monster while
missing his hand but when Charles offers
his hand back to him he's like well
thank you I think I deserve that wait
that's my hand oh and also turning into
lion oh that was kind of weird
oh my god this is crazy captain
something that makes more sense does
that cop have a cat in the car like
that's a thing what the k-9 unit find
out this film is too stupid to be in so
they have to settle for the feline unit
what the sweet hell am i watching
[Music]
what so what'd we miss
he turned to talk a monster they ripped
off the teachers hand and they get
chased by a cowboy and a cactus car and
then a cat can stand amidst be started
changing into all these other weird
faces and gleam this Thomas face for
some reason they pushed a button in his
car disappeared his car disappeared no
really what did we miss
I swear to god that's what happened to
telling me that all of this went down
right the hell out of nowhere in the
past five minutes yes okay but it still
looks like the same lame boring shit
yeah even what the cop is describing
sounds dull he didn't have no face a
blur yeah I don't know no no it was more
interesting than that and it is
admittedly we have that great writer
couldn't explain that better and the
prize should be focusing more on why a
cop has a cat in the car but I swear the
last five minutes we're totally insane
okay fine so it's not just weird adults
bunking teams I swear okay then you feed
tomorrow and
feed me
[Music]
so Tonya invites Charles to a photo
shoot she's doing in a cemetery remember
honey I want you home by 5:00
yes mommy and I'll be sure to pack extra
dieties - nobody loves a smartass Tanya
now I'm just here because Alan Thicke
was too expensive Charles mom is upset
though because she was him to bring a
teenage virgin for her to dine on and
he's taking too long
boy that's a sentence that doesn't roll
off the tongue easy God get it you stay
here I love you mom Wow even he can act
Paz how disgusting that sounded I love
you mom do you have to pay me double
every time we do a take of that time he
shows up but Charles mother might be
jumping the gun it finishes you somehow
what are your thoughts on assimilation
so they make it to the cemetery where
they plan to have a picnic as well as a
fake-out you surprised me
that deserves a picture I wrote
Shawshank didn't you imagine if a whole
generation took pictures for no reason
like a hippie horrifying dinner do you
really feel alone like the characters in
your story
his idea oh wow a superhot high school
girl with tons of friends and literally
no problems she must feel so alone
yeah you said all this crazy shit
happened earlier it did well we've been
here for 15 minutes since we came back
where is it look I know something crazy
will happen again just give it a chance
look there's something exciting has to
happen with him hey blow that's what's
up you catching the net hey they're
gonna Johnny with his pecker nozanne
he's a one ball man and he's off to the
road yo I was tapping buy me a bat
Malcolm you want to go get some snacks
for the snorefest
sure no I'm telling you 15 minutes ago
was crazy was so crazy oh I don't think
you're entering into the spirit of this
yeah so it goes catch it and sane again
let's see how they react to all this
kookiness yeah I guess I was a little
harsh on that homicidal monster I better
make sure my attackers okay thank you
baby
he's so deserved to get eaten she
stabbed him with a wine opener and he
complains about blood being on his shirt
[Music]
so is this an Eddie Murphy comedy now is
that him under all that makeup is he
playing everybody even the singing cop
comes along and takes him out you like
that I'm hoping that's gonna be my
catchphrase cop kebab like you know
something bad happens I think cop kebab
it's a work in progress but a pencil in
the brain just slows him down as he gets
back up and tries to shoot Joe Camel
I don't believe you fired a warning shot
officer this whole movie feels like a
warning shot for any future King written
films thank God that essential police
cat was there if it attacks Charles the
same way the rabbit attacks the Knights
of the Holy Grail you know a scary movie
shouldn't help there's many money Python
comparisons the chem messes him up good
and he goes home cryin to mama oh yeah
sure sir of course now you coming up now
you come in perfect anything exciting
happen while we were gone
anything exciting happen anything
exciting happen anything exciting happen
you're asking you if anything exciting
happened
anything yes exciting huh huh happen see
he turned into the Cowardly Lion again
his I was taken out with a wine opener
the cat fought him off like a pitbull
and the pencil was put through a cat
spraying coining the phrase cop kebab
really because it just looks like a
bunch of cops standing around a movie
works a ton of nothing happening and
then suddenly the dumbest stupidest shit
you can imagine for five minutes
let me guess it took place in five
minutes poor we don't have to take this
come Tamra we have more productive
things we could be doing do you know we
just want to be around you okay fine be
that way but at least look at this thing
on the wing before you go
[Music]
[Applause]
so Charles returns home damaged by the
cat and strangely enough even with all
the cat surrounding his place none of
them ever attack that really is like a
cat isn't it the fate of the world
depends on them stopping these creatures
from getting stronger and mr. Lumm fetch
assholes of nature
Charles mom tends to him next to the
Spencer's gift all because of course
they have that and she tries to heal his
wounds we've got to stay here until he
was stronger try to make yourself a dam
oh I think he's dim enough already she's
referring to him disappearing which he
can't quite pull off as back at the
crime scene we're giving arguably the
most honest of Stephen King cameos I am
taking the wrap on this not my fault I
just wrote the damn thing the directors
the one that made him look like The Lion
King speaking of directors there's
weirdly a ton of them in this scene
there's John Landis Clive Barker Joe
Dante tobe Hooper oh I get if they're
looking over this crime scene of a movie
to figure out how they can fix it let it
go boys this won't be nearly as good if
it was good this is officer Rayburn and
don't worry there's no cats in his
vehicle at all he carries a Chihuahua in
his car me I like squirrels awkward guy
yeah twelve o'clock do her parents know
a class one assault did not occur Karina
they know she managed to avoid being
raped by the bastard yes okay take the
rest of the night off
the cops get to the home of Charles and
his mother just interrupting this bit of
brilliant acting yeah I'd want to
disappear after giving that read they
seem to be invisible in the house as
officer ron perlman comes in to
obviously be the shitty is cop in an
already impressive lineup of shitty cops
[Music]
checkpoints in a no purpose to it by now
IRA what about the cats
what about Amaya look as someone who
already wore shitty cat makeup you make
some choices listen that little girl
needs a good smack on the butt and if
her mom and daddy won't do it
I'll happily volunteer and here I
thought sons test would be the most
pervy we got in this movie
stay away from her Soames he said that
like this happened before what is up
with this police force
stay away from her Soames there's not a
name for what I'm into but I still wish
to explore it the cops don't find them
there so they leave but it's advised
someone stay with Tanya while two other
cops stay at the house this is the best
meal I had since my wife passed on she
was delicious
[Music]
identify yourself maybe it was to win
okay every person in every movie ever
please cross the wind off your list of
suspects I know you always put it at
number one but at some point you have to
go by the numbers speaking of which
reason number 27 million these are the
worst cops ever my god they've been
young up to death let me take a peek
yeah it's probably the wind oh honey
we'll be expecting wind well the windows
drop by on the nose it turns out it's
Mary though as she invites herself in
oh no she pushed me I'm down it's like a
turn-on useless she pushed me I ain't
taking the rap on this not my fault he
does eventually find the strength to
recover from that push and he
demonstrates his cop skills by being the
worst shot ever what this looks like the
time to bravely run away we know no one
before calling these jokers this Maxine
I can't even do it justice just watch
there's blood everywhere
that's right once again Stephen King
tries to make a scary spectacle out of
time yes
tasty why does Damon King want to make
cart scary what's your deal how
embarrassing would that be to have that
on your death certificate and come on
after using the cop kebab line you
couldn't go with the incredibly obvious
porn on the cop
I see t-shirts up this man t-shirts well
nobody Bank on how ridiculous this is
so it's pussies galore is all the town's
cats head towards the house and once
again the cops have the most non caring
manner about the horrors in front of
them oh okay you don't approach a
psychopath dragging up leading high
schooler by her hair the same way you
tell a kid to put a Jolly Rancher back
put the girl down I'm going to count to
five war okay make it two great how am I
supposed to spank high school girls now
from here on out it just gets crazier
and never stops she blows up two cars
with just bullets burning this cop
knowing this department I wouldn't be
shocked if he just lit himself on fire
to make it easier on her once again the
kiss do nothing because they're cats and
Mary kidnaps Tanya and takes her to
Charles she's actually right he was very
clearly breathing when she said that
look at him he's dead I can tell by the
way his stomach goes up and down only
dead people do that so Mary plays his
favorite song in honor of him not being
dead she brings his body back to life I
think it's not really made that clear
I'm sure the non-existent book explained
it better and she forces them to dance
has she totally forgotten the details of
this documentary but don't worry the
sheriff and the cops Supercat from
earlier is here to save the day no
seriously I think this cat is from
Krypton watch
she window how can a cat break a friggin
window oh well I'm sure it's tied to the
turtle that's holding the earth or the
Dark Tower mythos or you have no
original source this time and you just
had to call it stupid haha stupid I am
taking the wrap on this - not my fault
he turns to the Mewtwo to try and suck
her virgin this away so they can live
but Tonya takes out his eye and now
suddenly the cat's attack a pretty
goddamn random time to say the least
fetching again that just kind of makes
sense a candle just sit there doing
nothing and then suddenly be like what
what what I love that when the sheriff
fires at her he gets Sylvester here -
well no time for a gun like our motto
says to serve and get the hell out of
here
this climax actually gets so funny you'd
swear it was comedic ly time just watch
come on you are going for a laugh there
you can put the Tom and Jerry sound
effect and it that's perfect but sit
bear trap some people hurt as he just
gets the hell back off and swings the
trap in the back of the monsters head
I'm moving to Derry Maine where it's
nice and quiet
once again decide to attack it random
and take Mary down and the sentence is
really hard to say without laughing they
scratch her so much he catches fire
Oh King I like your work when it's good
but I freaking love it what is bad I am
taking the rap on there so cats still
look uninterested - come on your closet
someone ablaze be impressed by something
and Tanya hugs the cops kid who made it
out alive
it's just you and me clueless just you
and me
yeah I'm pretty tired for the night take
the wheel Clovis that's right this was
all a really warped tootsies episode the
whole time because a minute that's the
only way any of this would make sense
this film is bananas absolute bonkers
and I loved every minute of it even the
slower boring parts which there's quite
a few of in the opening only adds to the
spontaneous surprise of insanity that
mounts to the climax of madness in the
end this is one of the most awesomely
bad Stephen King movies and it's simply
amazing I love its passion I love its
energy I love everything about it even
if I have no idea what it was trying to
be it's a masterpiece of epic
proportions and God bless every moment
of it oh great you missed the good stuff
again the ending was nothing but Stephen
King ridiculousness what were you guys
well we were watching the good Stephen
King movies good Stephen King movies
yeah the ones that you always see
there's a ton of and they never talked
about yeah we were actually trying to be
fair with the years and years you're
making fun of his worst adaptations huh
yeah I guess I have been pretty douchey
too legit talented guy all right I think
I've tried this fair thing you speak of
let's throw off the nostalgia wean right
next week I'm gonna count down the top
11 best Stephen King movie adaptations
and you can help just tell me in the
comments below which ones are your
favorite and you think should be on the
list
and I'll try my best to work them in I'm
the Nostalgia Critic and nostalgia ween
has just begun
seriously you should see that
[Music]
[Applause]
you
cop kebab
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and I swear this is totally a
coincidence
um it's save a pet whit specializes in
dogs and cats cats are wonderful pets as
you can see they take out
vampires sleepwalkers I guess uh but
this is also the charity that we're
doing this month for what you can do is
shows that you can volunteer as well as
donate this is a wonderful organization
it's it's a no-kill organization these
animals are so friggin cute and you can
go and you can help out or you can
donate cuz it's not government funded
relies on donations from wonderful
people like you so we're gonna show you
little snippet from from that video we
did though I highly recommend you see
the whole video so you can see the
wonderful work they do and these animals
are so cute enjoy
[Music]
I'm David dias I'm the development
manager for save a pet which is a
no-kill Animal Rescue and adoption
center in Grayslake Illinois we've been
in existence since 1972 so we're 46
years old and we started in Palatine and
then in 1995 we moved here to our
facility in Grayslake in what way does
save the pet save a pet well in 46 years
we've served about 63 thousand animals
we serve about a thousand animals on
average a year we deal with only cats
and dogs we are a true and pure no-kill
mission here at save abet so we don't
turn any animals away based on
temperament or behavior age their
history their medical needs anything
like that we are totally inclusive of
all animals and we do whatever it takes
to set them on the road to recovery and
adoption they always say it's better to
adopt rescue sure everyone says that you
know but yeah but but in your opinion
that why is that just so incredibly oh
well it's so incredibly important
because there are so many animals that
need to be adopted there are animals
waiting to become part of your family
and enrich your lives and instead of
going out and supporting someone who is
breeding more and more animals our
philosophy is that it makes more sense
for people to come adopt animals that
are here already in need oh this is kind
of special to us this is called our Tree
of Life and this is where some of our
major donors decide to buy a leaf and
they add their name to be recognized as
a major supporter of same path this is
not government funded no a lot of it
comes from donations and people giving
funds and stuff like that what is the
major difference between a place that
maybe has government funded I mean to be
general about it the expectations and
the regulation of the operations and
process these are totally different if
we were to take governmental funds they
would have an input and on our mission
which
is a pure no kill mission and we just
refused to waver from that we get it
done through individual donors and
business partners who help us out with
sponsoring different events and things
like that there's four or five different
save the pets throughout the world but
we serve Lake County and they're not
affiliated with each other but they're
all doing you know animal welfare work
based on the name I guess why would you
be the same a pet yes I make myself
lotta bottles is that what's one of the
more either amazing or inspiring like
pet stories that that's come through
here they use oh my gosh there's so many
like we see something every month that
just kind of as a jaw-dropper Willie
Nelson is a cat that came in that
suffered an accident out on the road
have got hit by a car and somebody found
it in a ditch and brought it to us three
of its four legs were fleeced basically
the fern skin was missing on three of
the lakes most every other animal rescue
shelter would find themselves in a
position where they would make the
choice I think to euthanize that animal
then we don't and so we spent a lot of
money
went through recovery and is with a
family today and you would have no idea
that Willie had that experience at all
so like all the furs back on his legs
over that just like that is crazy
totally crazy he just looks like a
normal kid a normal cat bopping around
and you know he would jump up on the
counter and you'd be like nice cat you
just would have no idea but they're like
I said very resilient and you know they
just adapt and overcome
so whether people want to volunteer
donate give time give money whatever
they want you to do any way you look
right and that camera and tell them what
website they can go to what place they
can go to need to go to WWE vApp Nilu RG
then you need to do that right now
because these animals are counting on
you thank you and they are adorable
these are cheap and Hannibal Spencer
you're so healthy man things done thanks
for coming out today thank you thank you
for having us yeah
[Music]
you